I've emailed the embassy but heard
nothing back from them I've tried
calling them but they're not answering
it's just a mess and there's so many
people all trying to get out now with
all the travel restrictions in place we
physically can't get home the
uncertainty kind of eats away at you
definitely day by day the chorus of
Britons caught up in coronavirus travel
turmoil is growing louder they're stuck
and they're scared it's a double blow
for medics who want to fly home to see
loved ones and to save lives
got these skills I you know can use at
home to help through this time and I'm
just sat here you know not knowing when
I'm gonna be able to get out it's
obviously quite a scary feeling there
are between 300,000 and 1 million
Britons around the world trying to
return to the UK those in places like
Australia India and parts of Indonesia
are in a particular bind because of
travel constraints and distance now more
than 80 countries have introduced travel
restrictions on their borders airlines
are also halting services Emirates has
temporarily stopped all flights while
Virgin Atlantic has suspended flights
into Gatwick Airport it means in some
cases such as Peru the UK is chartering
planes to bring stranded travelers home
Boris Johnson stuck up for diplomats
who've been working around the clock to
save stranded Britons there is a massive
massive a repatriation effort going on
Jim comfort for one Derbyshire group
stuck here in India they filmed the
inside of a hostel where they've been
forced to stay little chance for social
distancing flights like theirs have
angered mp's we just needed to have seen
the better advice faster I think now
we're in a situation where the
government has to step in with the
airlines and start organising
repatriation flights expect more charter
flights to the rescue
calls even from MPs for military
aircraft to help testing times and no
easy answers Deborah Haynes Sky News